bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple on va parler de l'iphone dit
l'iphone disent qu'ils de ce qui avait
été dit aurait déçu on est déçu parce
qu'il n'y avait pas eu les chiffres
attendus par apple les chiffres ont été
vraiment moindre par contre
effectivement on sait qu'apple a eu un
record au quatrième trimestre 2010 est
un chiffre record un résultat juste
énorme et pourtant avec un iphone 10 qui
décevaient et qui était pas à la hauteur
d'un point de vue vente
a priori ce ne serait pas exactement ça
serait même plutôt inverse l'iphone 10
pour être une vraie boîte à cash pour
apple il s'en va le regarder maintenant
l'iphone bis a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre avant son arrivée on connaissait
pas son nom on savait qu'elle avoir un
iphone 8 on savait pas qu'elle ait être
réellement les faux d'anniversaire une
fois qu'on l'a su il a fait encore plus
couler d'encre parce qu'effectivement il
avait un design assez différent par
rapport au reste de la gamme et puis un
produit qui est tellement c'est une fois
de plus comme ils révolutionnent comme
la vision en tout cas tout ce que devait
être l'iphone pour les dix ans à venir
pour apple un produit en tout cas qui
est vraiment sexy on aime on n'aime pas
on n l'encoche condamne pas l'encoche
peu importe c'est pas le débat toujours
est il qu'aujourd'hui cet iphone
semblait en tout cas décevoir de par ses
ventes
sauf que en définitive il semblerait que
ce soit pas particulièrement ça
effectivement c'est un fait les ventes
de smartphones dix minutes les gens ne
renouvellent pas leur téléphone tous les
ans pour plus attendre tous les deux ans
pour les renouveler le côté on est sur
des investissements qui sont quand même
très lourd ça coûte très cher on les
finance ce soit directement dans un
chèque ou alors en passant par son
opérateur n'avait qu'un forfait
augmenter tous les mois mais dans tous
les cas ce qui est sûr c'est que à un
moment ou un autre sur smartphone on ne
paye pas c'est un peu planté en tout cas
des informations qui sont sorties n'ont
pas forcément été peut-être vu de la
bonne manière parce que ce qu'il faut
comprendre que vous voulez c'est qu'il
ya deux possibilités pour un fabricant
de smartphones d'augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires soit d'augmenter les volumes
mais avec des gens qui changent moins
souvent à leur téléphone
c'est quand même un peu compliqué même
si certains produits révolutionnaires et
des guillemets le consommateur va pas
forcément se jeter dessus directement et
renouvelé même s'ils sont passés à la
caisse
ya pas très longtemps donc ça
effectivement c'est compliqué la
deuxième solution c'est d'augmenter le
prix c'est vraiment ce qu'a fait apple
avec ce produit hors norme ce produit
anniversaire en tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'il a été vendu d'un point de vue
marketing comme étant vraiment un
produit exceptionnel
la stratégie d'apple s'était vraiment
dire on sort le produit dans la gamme
assez classique 8,8 plus est le produit
anniversaire le produit exceptionnel la
révolution pour nous cette année c'est
l'iphone 10 ce qui permet effectivement
de légitimer un prix y ait plus de 1000
euros 1104 euros et 1300 pour les les
modèles les plus haut de gamme
effectivement un peu là fait le choix de
sortir un iphone très cher et dernière
et ça ça a été a priori la stratégie
gagnante pour eux selon counterpoint le
revenu moyen estimé par iphone serait
passé de 694 $ au premier trimestre
17 à 7 196 dollars pour premier
trimestre 2010 8 c'est à dire 100 $ de
plus par smartphone par unité vendue
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais en imaginant s'assure une moyenne
c'est vraiment énorme
au quatrième trimestre 2010 est l'iphone
10 représente à lui seul 35 % des
bénéfices mondiaux de smartphones
l'iphone 8 est à 19,1 pour cent le
galaxy note 8 mai cap 3,9 pour cent et
si on cumule tous les chiffres d'apple
de tous les smartphones apple dans ses
meilleures ventes on arrive à 84 8% pour
apple et 5 6% pour samsung apple et
samsung représentent à eux deux 90 4% et
tout le reste effectivement dédié aux
autres produits et aux autres fabricants
ces chiffres viennent évidemment sont
toujours à prendre avec des pincettes
non en tout cas ce qu'il en ressort est
ce qu'on va très clairement là dedans
c'est que la stratégie pour apple
d'avoir un produit très cher et très
grand public malgré tout aidé la bonne
là où effectivement samsung vous propose
un galaxy note 8 très cher à plus de
1000 euros mais le galaxy note suite
semble être moins le produit grand
public que les l'iphone 10 a contrario
le produit grand public c'était le
galaxy s suite en 2017 et le galaxy s 9
et asef plus belle et vida mans en 2018
donc forcément des produits qui à la
base sont un peu moins cher et vous
ramener forcément un peu moins de
chiffre d'affaires aux fabricants ce
qu'il faut aussi comprendre c'est que
lorsqu'un peu la sortie ces trois
produits septembre de l'année dernière
le 8 8 plus et le dise il était évident
que les personnes qui allaient changer
aller plus passer sur un iphone disque
qui était vraiment le nouveau design et
qui apporte est vraiment la nouveauté
par rapport aux iphone 8 et 8 plus et ça
forcément ça permet d'engendrer un peu
plus de cash à apple donc la stratégie
est gagnante la stratégie est la bonne
apple une fois de plus ne s'est pas
planté ce qui est aussi très clair c'est
que apple se diversifient mais qu à voir
avec le home pod qui est sorti ya pas
très longtemps alors qui n'est pas
forcément trouvé encore sa place dans
les foyers aujourd'hui mais ça ne
saurait tarder ce quelque chose qui va
encore évoluer on devrait avoir un homme
pod un peu plus petite probablement
moins cher pour concurrencer directement
google sur ce marché là apple va
vraiment diversifié son offre et en plus
de ça on va en parler très très très
prochainement il devrait y avoir plein
de nouveaux smartphones plein de
nouveaux iphone cette année bon rester
qualité parce que ça on va en parler
très très très vite et vous allez voir
que du côté de chez apple il se passe
beaucoup de choses dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
trouvez que en tout cas les fans qui
s'étaient introduits plutôt bien réussi
est ce que vous l'avez acheté est-ce que
vous avez été content est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que apple est vraiment
supérieure à samsung en termes de ventes
de smartphones
est ce que au contraire vous pensé quand
même que samsung est plutôt bien placé
et qu'ils sont tous les deux dans une
position de leadership
un couloir un coup l'autre mais ce qu'il
faut vraiment retenir que ça c'est que
apple ne s'est pas planté a priori
contrairement à tout ce qui avait été
dit sur sa politique de prix et dans la
mesure où ils sont pas plantés
ils vont continuer c'est à dire que les
iphone haut de gamme de 2018 et 2019 et
les années suivantes resteront très cher
et seront probablement encore très près
cher il faut rester mesuré dans tout ça
il y aura forcément un produit toujours
à plus de 1000 euros on va imaginer un
iphone 10 plus avec un grand écran
toujours avec une dalle oled on devrait
aussi avoir un iphone avec un écran lcd
un iphone 10 avec un écran lcd qui sera
beaucoup moins cher ce sera probablement
un iphone
ses-2 ça on le verra l'avenir donc
rester connecté parce que je vous dis
une fois de plus on va beaucoup en
parler ils vont rester toujours dans
cette gamme de prix du produit hyper
sexy très cher ils en vendront moins
mais comme il est cher ça sera très
intéressant pour eux et puis ensuite les
produits qui vont rejoindre le plus qui
seront quand même relativement cher
aussi parce qu'on sait que apple quoi
qu'il se passe à une politique de prix
qui est très élevé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire comme d'hab vous invite à
vous abonner à blesser des jolies pouces
et puis on reste connectés parce que
vous allez voir il ya plein de choses
qui vont arriver plein de super sexy
super cool donc restez connectés à très
bientôt soyez sages je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous 5
[Musique]